president Trump disavows the send her
back crowd chants Democrats lament John
McCain a little late and the squad
continues its radical push I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
all righty so we do have a lot coming up
for you today on today's show and let's
just jump right in so president Trump
over the last 24 hours was in a whole
lot of hot water why well he went to one
of his rallies and this came in the
aftermath of tweets that he sent earlier
this week he sent tweets on Sunday and
those tweets he told a bunch of
progressive congresswoman that they
should go back to their home countries
the problem being that three of the four
progressive congresswoman who is talking
about were born right here and the
fourth is a naturalized American citizen
so telling them to go back to their home
countries because you don't like their
politics that's not good that's bad
stuff and then President Trump morphed
that argument into what I really meant
was if you don't love the country you
can leave it at any time well that's not
an unusual argument that's had a place
in American politics for a very long
time it's not really an argument so much
as it is an emotional appeal if you
don't like it you're free to leave in
fact Hollywood stars use this all the
time as well you know if Trump is
elected I'm gonna move up to Canada and
then nobody ever actually moves up to
Canada this sort of argument has been
used really since the beginning of the
Republic if you don't like it here you
can always take off no one's keeping you
here okay that's that that argument is
not particularly objectionable on its
face the argument that is more
objectionable is go back to your home
country
that's objectionable maybe xenophobic
but the the president from Ben's at a
rally and the rally happened in North
Carolina this happened two nights ago
and the President of the United States
was talking about el hanout mark Ella
Hannah Mar is the worst of the so-called
squad the squad is composed of course of
AOC and Ilhan Omar and Rasheeda Talib
and Ayanna Presley and Ilhan Omar is the
most radical member of the squad not
necessarily in terms of her domestic
politics but certainly in terms of the
language she uses about the United
States the language that she uses about
terror groups her history of going easy
on for example Isis recruits you wrote a
letter to a judge recommending the
people attempting to join Isis be given
more lenient sentences her her
anti-semitic comments have been routine
and common and so Trump went after Al
Hanuman on her record and then the crowd
taking a cue from his original tweets
earlier this week started chanting send
her back and President Trump didn't say
anything at the rally he kind of just
stood there and took it now the
president should have done is you should
have immediately
stepped in and said hold up a second now
vote her out right not send her back
we're not sending any American citizens
back anywhere and in fact it's on
American to suggest that the exercise of
the First Amendment should subject you
to deportation and that's it that's a
bad thing obviously but Trump really
didn't know what to do on that stage so
a lot of folks took that as president
Trump is cheering it president Trump is
is fine with it well over the last 24
hours the president retracted that
basically he came out against that chant
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about your cell phone
plan so you're probably spending a
fortune on your cell phone plan you're
thinking why am i spending this much
money on my cell phone plan I'm not
using anywhere near the kind of data
that I'm receiving for the price well
mint mobile will provide you the same
premium network coverage you're used to
but at a fraction of the cost
mint mobile makes it easy to cut your
wireless bill down to just 15 bucks a
month every plan comes with unlimited
nationwide talk and text with mint
mobile stop paying for unlimited data
you're never gonna use choose between
plans with 3 8 or 12 gigs of 4G LTE data
use your own phone with any mint mobile
plan keep your same phone number along
with all of your existing context it's
your old wireless bill start saving
right now with mint mobile to get your
new wireless plan for just 15 bucks a
month and get the plan shipped to your
door for free go to mint mobile comm
slash Ben that's em int mo bi le comm
slash Penn mint mobile comm slash man
cut your wireless Vil to 15 bucks a
month at mint mobile comm slash Ben
there's no reason for you to be spending
enormous quantities of cash to pay for
data that you are never going to use you
could have exactly the same coverage for
a fraction of the price mint mobile comm
slash Ben and get your new wireless plan
for just 15 bucks a month and the plan
ship to your door for free mint
mobile.com slash Ben okay so president
Trump yesterday did the right thing and
the right thing was for him to disavow
this chance and that is what he did so
he's in the Oval Office he's no presser
and he was asked about this by the media
and he disavowed it he said I don't like
the chant and now the media will see as
they covered it the media were not
interested in his apology right the
media are not interested in the walk
back the media want him to continue
saying what he is what he was saying
earlier this week and they want to
continue pushing the notion that
Republicans are by and large racist and
xenophobic and want to send everybody
who doesn't look like them back to their
home countries Trump's response to the
send them back
now if you're a good American you should
be pretty happy that the president
backed off of this because whether you
like Trump or not it is not good for our
politics as I pointed out repeatedly
yesterday on the show it is very bad for
our politics to have political leaders
saying things that are morally
indefensible so if a political leader or
going along with things that are morally
indefensible so if a political leader
backs off of that thing that's good for
the country generally speaking here as
president from doing that yesterday good
for him this is the right thing he likes
you don't get full credit because your
earlier tweets sort of led this thing
off and you also don't get full credit
because you didn't stop the chance but
you certainly get partial credit for
doing the right thing now and at least
saying to your own base let's not make
this thing a thing at our rallies right
how about how about not every rally
includes they send them back chant
because come on okay so here is
president Trump backing off a bit when
your supporters last night we're
challenging chanting sent her back why
didn't you stop them why didn't you ask
them to stop saying that
well number one I think I did I started
speaking very quickly
it really was a loud I disagree with her
by the way
but it was quite a chant and I felt a
little bit badly about it but I will say
this I did and I started speaking very
quickly but it started out rather rather
fast as you probably noticed you'll tell
your supporters never do well I would
say that I was not happy with it I
disagree with him but again I didn't say
I didn't say that they did okay so there
is Trump backing off of it and listen
Trump's followers know the Q which has
cut this bleep out right stop that right
now I don't like it now did President
Trump stop it in his tracks no I pointed
this out yesterday okay there's not a
great excuse for that it is true that if
you look at his body language normally
if you watch any Trump rallies when
people were chanting lock her up the
president basically would walk away from
the microphone and then he would proceed
to kind of conduct the audience or not
along with the chant or clap along with
the Cheney didn't see any of that from
president from that doesn't mean that he
was actively putting a damper on it he
obviously was not but now he's actively
putting a damper on it are the media
though going to take that of course not
so CNN ran a headline and said Trump
claims to disavow chants
he no no he disavowed it disavowal is a
is a pattern of speech in which you
disavow something you can't claim to
disavow something without disavowing the
thing and if i disavow white supremacy
you can't say shapiro claims to disavow
white supremacy shapiro disavows white
supremacy is the headline shapiro
disavows whatever like a disavowal is
where you disavow a thing
CNN wasn't having any of that CNN's
Chiron's yesterday ran things like
president disavows the disavow is chant
while at the same time maintaining tweet
from Sunday's okay why don't you
actually just report what he did
yesterday you can give the context
that's fine but your chi runs don't
actually have to be 500 word essays
about why you find his words
insufficient at this point that's not
journalism anymore now your
editorializing so the the greatest of
objective reporters among us Don Lemon
and Chris Cuomo decided that they were
going to demonstrate that the president
didn't do enough at the rally which is
true he didn't do enough at the rally
but then he came out and he said okay
this is bad I don't like it so instead
on CNN yesterday they said watch we're
gonna stay silent for 13 seconds this is
what it looks like when you don't say
anything for 13 seconds while people say
bad things just bear with me don't say
anything don't say anything for and I'm
gonna start the stopwatch just don't say
anything let's see you know they're just
sitting there Chris Cuomo sipping his
coffee so is Don Lemon and they just sit
there for 13 seconds and this is
supposed to it's the 13 seconds that
mattered most in American history and
there's Chris Cuomo doing his chin hair
it was a long time wasn't it a long time
I had several different thoughts about
you during that moment did you get my
point
I do a hundred percent and he's lying
he's lying because he liked it he needs
it at this point
and he could have stopped it but he
didn't he wants those people to have
their outrage fed and then he wants the
rest of us to think what he does isn't
that outrageous so question why didn't
he just double down on it I mean
President Trump is very fond of doubling
down on things so if he liked it he
couldn't make it the staple at every
single one of his rallies remember he
did that listen the media had a bleep
fit when they came to lock her up and
the president did not back off lock her
up the president started chanting lock
her up hey Donald Trump is not famous
for backing off things
he likes he moves on them like a bleep
brand mean like this is when President
Trump likes things he goes after this is
not a typical president Trump move is to
back off this this comment okay but what
is most disingenuous about the media
coverage of President Trump backing off
of this and telling his crowd to stop
all of this is the routine that the
media do now with regard to John McCain
and this is how you got Trump was having
a conversation with somebody last night
and he's asking why is it that so many
Republicans are having a tough time
disavowing bad things that Trump says
and I said because most Republicans and
most conservatives feel that they are
not going to be given credit for doing
the correct moral thing and that in
essence we're not going to trust you
guys to make those judgments because the
fact is that you would rip any
Republican the same way that you are
ripping Trump you just hate Trump more
because he doesn't have your highfalutin
speech patterns and then you can see a
pure example of this so the media
yesterday they were they were aghast at
Trump of course which I was not pleased
with President Trump you go back and
listen to the show obviously but the
media were aghast at President Trump and
what did they start doing they started
talking about the wonders of John McCain
now when I talked yesterday on the
program about John McCain and John
McCain shutting down a person at one of
his rallies who suggested that Barack
Obama was a Muslim I said that was the
right thing to do
good for John McCain now I can say that
because I supported John McCain in 2008
when he ran against Barack Obama I voted
for him I stumped for him I raised money
for him the members of the media who are
now coming out of the woodwork to praise
John McCain well a little late guys a
little late because it turns out that
wasn't what you were saying at the time
I'll show you in just a second and then
you wonder why Republicans don't trust
you when it comes to your judgement on
racism why we think that you're a bunch
of political phonies and hacks when you
express your outrage at what the
president is saying I'll explain in just
one second first nowadays there are so
many different types of car on the road
there's really no way the auto parts
store can stock everything why wait in
line to find the right part that's
probably overpriced when you can do it
all with the convenience of rock
wireless and the internet was made for a
lot of wonderful things why not for auto
parts Rock Auto comm is a family
business serving Auto Parts customers
online for 20 years go to Rock Auto calm
and shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers they have
everything from engine control modules
and brake parts to tail lamps
even new carpet whether it's for your
classic or daily driver get everything
you need and a few easy clicks delivered
directly to your door the Rock auto comm
catalog is unique and remarkably easy to
navigate quickly see all the parts
available for your vehicle choose the
brands specifications and prices that
you prefer best of all prices at
rockauto.com
are always reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers so
why would you spend up to twice as much
for the same exact auto parts they have
amazing selection they have great prices
reliably low prices all the parts your
car will ever need check them out at
Rock Auto calm again Rock Auto calm go
to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
right Shapiro's in there how did you
hear about us box so that they know that
we sent you right shapiro again and that
how did you hear about our spots in Rock
auto comm so they know that we say ok so
as I say the media aghast at president
Trump and playing and paying tribute to
John McCain so here is Don Lemon last
night saying where is John McCain what
whatever happened to Republicans like
John McCain I'm so tired of the media
but by the way yeah I think it'll be
hilarious when mmm eight years from now
that's it let's say that Donald Trump
wins and then there's another race after
after that and then the Republican loses
so is we've you know things which as
they do tend to every eight years in the
United States it's hard to win a third
term for your party as Hillary Clinton
proved let's say that they switch so 10
years from now when another Republican
is running for the nomination in for the
24 the 2028 election it's going to be
highly highly entertaining watching the
media talk about the halcyon days of
President Trump and his moderate policy
proposals and the fact that he was
willing to reach across the aisle
because this is what the media do with
every Republican as soon as they are no
longer a threat then they become
wonderful people again so here is John
McCain here was Don Lemon on John McCain
last night I want everyone to be
respectful and let's make sure we are
because that's the way politics should
be conducted in America so let's make
sure
we're all respectful those were the days
huh the crowd booed Barack Obama
Senator McCain got them cheering when he
said being respectful as the way
politics should be conducted in America
boy that would be nice to hear again
seems like an awfully long time ago
doesn't it now I'm not suggesting that
American politics has always been
respectful I'm not that naive but there
was a time when at least people tried
right okay yeah John McCain now people
tried people listen I agree I
specifically mentioned this incident on
yesterday's show John McCain handled
that correctly when it came to Barack
Obama being called the Muslim flashback
October 11 2008 there's a man named Don
Lemon you may have heard of him from
five seconds ago on CNN and Don Lemon
tweeted this out the question is do you
think the McCain campaign is creating a
political environment that is inciting
hate and hate speech the same the same
Don Lemon who was talking about the
civility and wonder of American politics
in 2008 and the fundamental decency of
John McCain was suggesting that
Republicans and John McCain's specific
campaign was creating a political
environment this is a direct quote is
creating a political environment that is
inciting hate and hate speech in other
words you wanna know why Republicans
don't trust you guys on this crap
because you saved the same exact crap
about every Republican including John
McCain so you're going around praising
John McCain as this wonderful civil
fellow and when it came to comedy in the
US Senate when it came to treatment of
his political opponents I think there is
truth to that but you didn't treat him
like that and you're full of it now
you're full of it now and so what
Republicans say is listen if we're gonna
get treated like garbage and we're gonna
get treated like we are inciting hate
and hate speech then you might as well
have a president who's gonna punch
people in the face that's how you got
Trump guys this is how you got Trump and
and this was the meme yesterday you had
Chuck Schumer yesterday on the floor of
the Senate saying listen what President
Trump does is so vile and so terrible
and so unprecedented I lament the fact
that there is no John McCain anymore
John McCain is long gone what are we
supposed to do what was shouted and
chanted at the rally last night without
the president of
was despicable despicable the only way
President Trump will stop is when
Republicans on the other side have the
honor the decency the courage to tell
him to stop history will show this this
is a moment
there's no John McCain anymore when this
kind of bitter racism emerged that his
town-hall meeting okay there's no John
McCain anymore amazing let me help let
me just let me just flashback
okay I'm gonna flashback to the 2008
race John Lewis the Civil Rights icon
and George a Congress person was he was
tapped by John McCain as a possible
advisor here is what John Lewis said
about John McCain at the time and now
John Louis of course leading the charge
against Donald Trump here's what John
Lewis the Civil Rights icon had to say
about John McCain circa 2008 this is
October 11th 2008 again quote this is
from Politico Civil Rights icon and
Georgia Congressman John Lewis is
accusing John McCain and Sarah Palin of
stoking hate likening the atmosphere at
Republican campaign events to those
featuring George Wallace a
segregationist former governor of
Alabama and presidential candidate
McCain's campaign has responded with a
statement in the candidates name urging
Barack Obama to repudiate Lewis's
comments did Barack Obama repudiate
Lewis's comments no no he did not
Barack Obama sat back and allowed John
Lewis without any sort of blowback to
suggest that John McCain was running a
George Wallace Lite campaign so do I
want to hear from you guys now what a
wonderful guy John McCain was and how
John McCain was the model for American
politics and Oh for the days of John
McCain know you guys can shut the hell
up you shut right up because you were
crapping all over John McCain I was
there at the time I remember it you were
crapping all over it you were suggesting
that he was a racist and a bigot you
were suggesting that he was a vicious
campaigner who is attempting to knife
innocent Barack Obama in the back you
did all of this and then you wonder why
Republicans were like well that's not
even true about John McCain so if you're
gonna say it over and over about us then
we may as well get a guy who will Club
you this is how you got from nobody's
gonna play by your rules if you don't
abide by your own rules cuz your rules
don't exist your rules are a bunch of
nonsense John Lewis said George Wallace
never threw a bomb he never fired a gun
but he created a climate and the
conditions that encouraged vicious
attacks against innocent
Americans who are simply trying to
exercise their constitutional rights
because of this atmosphere of hate four
little girls were killed on a Sunday
morning when a church was bombed in
Birmingham Alabama Senator McCain and
governor Palin are sowing the seeds of
hatred and division and there is no need
for this hostility in our political
discourse he said that about John McCain
in 2008 John McCain and it's the exact
same language they are now calling
Donald Trump George Wallace
you keep saying everybody's George
Wallace eventually people conclude that
no one is George Wallace and you guys
can just you can go walk take a long
walk write off a short pier
now this is particularly true when you
look at the contrasting coverage between
how the media cover Donald Trump and how
the media covered the radicalism and
hate emanating from the Democratic Party
so Donald Trump tweeted out this morning
he tweeted out quote it is amazing how
the fake news media became crazed
quote-unquote over the chant send her
back by a packed arena a record crowd in
the great state of North Carolina
you gotta love how President Trump under
all circumstances will never miss an
opportunity to point out that he has
amazing crowd says but he's totally calm
and accepting of the most vile and
disgusting statements made by the three
radical left Congress women mainstream
media which have lost all credibility
has either officially or unofficially
become a part of radical left democrat
party it is a sick partnership so
pathetic to watch they even covered a
tiny stage crowd as they greeted
foul-mouthed Omar in Minnesota a state
which I will win in 2020 because they
can't stand her and her hatred of our
country and they appreciate all that
I've done for them opening up mining and
much more which has led to the best
employment in economic year in
Minnesota's long and beautiful history
unquote president from me wrong about
this he's not wrong about this media
attention to the crowd chant which was
appropriate it was appropriate but you
know what is inappropriate ignoring the
fact that there was a terrorist attack
on an ice facility over the weekend and
the person who committed that terrorist
attack was a member of an tyfa and that
member of an Tifa was suggesting that
the ice facility was actually a quote
concentration camp and then a bunch of
top Democratic congresswoman the members
of the squad were specifically asked by
the rebel and the daily caller
whether in fact it would condemn that
ice terror attack and the only one who
eventually said she might condemn acts
of violence is aoc all the others have
remained silent there is no further
comment from Ayane Presley or Ella Hahn
Omar or Rashida to leap about any of
that and still no one has asked aoc
about the incitement charge so everybody
on the left keeps saying that Donald
Trump is inciting violence
everything he says incites violence he's
gonna be responsible for millions of
deaths he's gonna be responsible for an
enormous number of people getting hurt
he's gonna be responsible for violence
upon violence upon violence and this is
the line about Donald Trump because of
his rhetoric a person walked over to a
nice facility and tried to blow it up
with a canister of fuel and hunt was
holding rifle and shot to death for his
trouble while quoting AOC and they won't
even ask aoc about it now
I don't think AOC is responsible for
that guy and I don't think that unless
Donald Trump is calling for violence
he's responsible for violence but that's
not the media standard and that's not a
OC standard so when it comes to
imbalance of coverage that would be the
imbalance of coverage right there which
is a bigger story an attempted terror
attack on a nice detainment facility you
know an actual act of violence or the
president saying stupid garbage as is
his usual wants on all days ending and
why I understand it's a big story when
the president says something
particularly when he sets a new low I
get it I covered it this week go back
and listen to the show I'm just pointing
out there's a slight imbalance in
political coverage and so is President
Trump and he is not wrong about this and
as we will see the squad is not letting
up the squad is not letting up in any
way we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about something that we
can all agree is awesome and that of
course is saving cash honey
is a free tool that you download to your
computer's browser while you shop online
honey scans the internet for coupon
codes and other discounts and then it
automatically applies the coupon with
the biggest savings to your cart a
checkout just like magic so you might
ask how do I know honey has my back does
it really work well you know these I'm
telling you number one I use honey
myself and it saves me money nearly
every time I shop not only did honey
test over 1 billion promo codes last
year it actually applied 185 million
67,000 86 working codes to people's
orders that is a lot of real life
savings and again you should be using
honey because I
honey it is free to use it is easy to
install on your computer in just two
clicks you don't have to overthink that
promo box you can go searching around on
the random websites for the promo code
get honey for free at join honey calm
slash patent again that is join honey
calm / Ben J oin honey calm / Ben honey
online savings simplified no reason free
to be spending full price on products
when honey can literally be doing your
shopping for you it works on all the
major shopping sites including Amazon
which is where I tend to shop check them
out it join honey calm / madness join
honey calm / then so as I as Trump says
and as I say the media imbalance in
coverage between what Trump says and
what members of the Democratic Party say
astonishing now I'm not saying that I
honor Presley should receive the same
kind of press that the president does
he's the president she's a congress
person but you would think there might
be a story in the mainstream media when
Ayanna Presley says over the last
weekend that black people aren't black
unless they agree with her gay people
aren't gay unless they agree with her
and Muslim people aren't Muslim unless
they agree with ohon Omar you might
think it would receive you know like a
little more coverage when for example a
OC suggests that ice agents are blatant
racists you know the weekend after a
terror attack on a nice facility so
yesterday
AOC was speaking with Kevin McHale inan
who is the acting head of department of
homeland security and she went after ice
agents labeling 10,000 of them racist
now she's doing this on the basis of bad
information I'll explain what she gets
right which is not much and what she
gets wrong in just a second but here she
is maligning ice agents across the
country as racists and bigots and
brutality Laden pieces of human debris
hey this is pretty vicious stuff that
she is saying about you know the people
who are putting their lives on the line
to protect people on the border and also
to who go out of their way to save
thousands of lives every year for
Refugees who are trying to cross the Rio
Grande and have to be escorted to ports
of entry here is here's aoc going after
Kevin Mack Elena and after ice agents
more generally we do not have a
dehumanizing culture at CBP this is an
agency that rescues 4,000 people a year
that's absolutely committed to the
well-being of everyone that they
interact with and
there's a dehumanizing call and mr.
secretary I'm so you don't think that
having 10,000 officers in a violent
racist group sharing rape memes of
members of Congress points to any
concern of it dehumanized culture
congresswoman those posts are
unacceptable they're being investigated
but I don't think it's fair to apply
them to the entire organization or that
even the members of that group believed
or supported those posts
okay Mecca Lee none is totally right
about this so here is what happened okay
there according to Pro Publica they send
members of a secret Facebook group for
current and former Border Patrol agents
jokes about the deaths of migrants
discussed throwing burritos at Latino
members of Congress visiting a detention
facility in Texas on Monday and posted a
vulgar illustration depicting aoc
engaged in oral sex with the detained
migrant according to screenshots of
their postings all this of course is
disgusting ProPublica says in one
exchange group members responded with
indifference and wisecracks to the post
of a news story about a sixteen-year-old
Guatemalan migrant who died in May while
in custody at a Border Patrol station in
Weslaco Texas one member posted a Jif of
Elmo with the quote oh well created in
August 2016 the Facebook group is called
I'm 1015 and boasts roughly 9500 members
from across the country 1015 is Border
Patrol code for aliens in custody the
group described itself in an online
introduction as a forum for funny and
serious discussion about work with the
patrol remember you're never alone in
this family the introduction said and
then they talk about these specific
comments ok so were these comments that
were posted by the moderators no these
were not comments posted by the
moderators on Facebook like this
demonstrates such an ignorance of how
Facebook works on Facebook when you have
a group like this there are the
moderators who post stories and then
there are people who comment under the
stories and you can go through virtually
any Facebook page I promised you a OCS
Facebook page too and you can find
people who are members of her page or
fans of her page who are commenting on
stories and saying vile disgusting
things does that malign all of AO C's
Facebook page or all of this border
patrol Facebook page no it doesn't
because no one reads the comments on
Facebook or if they do it's like five
people reading each other's comments so
is there a subset of people who ought to
be called out and prosecuted and
disciplined whatever the law demands of
course
and by the way McInally nan says that he
says people have been put on
administrative
people haven't put on desk jobs people
are being punished we're investigating
all of this but she's maligning ten
thousand Border Patrol agents and former
Border Patrol agents because there were
like five posts apparently that were
ugly on a on a Border Patrol page over
the course of years presumably I mean
the head of the Congressional Hispanic
Caucus Joaquin Castro reviewed the
Facebook discussions was incensed he
said it confirms some of the worst
criticisms of Customs and Border
Protection these are clearly agents who
are desensitized to the points of being
dangerous to migrants and their
co-workers so AOC takes some bad
comments on a Facebook page and then
uses it to smear the entire border
patrol agency now
AOC then turned back to trump and she
says that Trump's ugly comments this
week put millions of Americans in danger
so she is the one who's constantly
suggesting that if you make a comment
politically that does not call for
violence against anybody they are
putting millions not just her not just
oh hello mark millions of Americans in
danger right so here she is explaining
that Trump is inciting violence
basically threats to individual members
of Congress but it is about creating a
volatile environment in this country
through violent rhetoric that puts
anyone except that she has a Kunis those
exact same thing right she just last
week she and her friends went on
national TV on CBS and they made exactly
the same claim about Pelosi they said
that Pelosi was creating incitement of
violence against members of Congress
here's the question for AOC so if
Trump's rhetoric which admittedly was
bad earlier this week I have said that 1
million times this week I can't say it
any more times this way I mean I can but
it would get boring at a certain point
you know my opinion on this I hit him as
hard as anybody right or left over the
chance at the rally yesterday everyone
knows this this is undeniable ok so she
says that that sort of language leads to
violence again there was an ice attack
there's an attack on an ice facility by
a person quoting aoc last weekend and
she's back out there suggesting that
homeland security agents and Border
Patrol agents across the country are
systemically desensitized
Islands and are basically violent
racists and no one will ask our question
about it no one you think maybe that's
why so many conservatives are just
discounting whatever the media have to
say even when the media are making a
proper criticism of President Trump
because they say listen your criticism
of President Trump comes in the context
of you being smear artists and it
doesn't just it's not just limited to
AOC and Ilhan Omar she's going after
Trump this week but where is the media
coverage of Ilhan Omar's radicalism so
here's a on Omar yesterday being
surrounded by media and declaring the
President Trump is a fascist okay you
may not like president Trump's rhetoric
I don't like President Trump's rhetoric
a lot of times but if President Trump
weren't actual fascists do you think
that Ilhan Omar would be able to run
around the country saying that President
Trump was an actual fascist the mark of
fascism generally is not allowing your
political opponents to call you a
fascist all that often they hear Zohan
Omar making that case we have said this
president is racist
we have condemned I believe he is
fastest I want to remind people that
this is what this president and his
supporters have taught our country that
is supposed to be a country where we
allow democratic debate and dissent to
take place and so this is not about me
this is about us fighting for what this
country truly should be okay so
President Trump is a fascist important
to point out at this point that Ilhan
Omar has stood against sanctions against
both Venezuela as well as Iran so when
it comes to actual fascism on planet
Earth
she seems pretty okay with it based on
the based on country of origin the only
countries that she seems pretty down on
in the leadership of those countries she
really is not fond of President Trump
obviously and he's not fond of her
either but calling him a fascist is
obviously untrue and she hates Israel
right she's so this is the part where it
becomes maddening so Ilhan Omar pursued
what is indeed an anti-semitic trope
yesterday now not even a trophy was an
Instamatic policy not anti-semitic just
by my lights and he's met it by the
lights of Nancy Pelosi one month ago
said in front of a pack that BDS boycott
divestment and sanctions from Israel is
anti-semitic policy that it is bigoted
policy well yesterday
Ilhan omar sponsored a resolution
not only backing boycotts and divestment
and sanctions against Israel but
comparing Israel to Nazi Germany from
1933 to 1941 you know the place that
killed all the Jews she compared the
Jewish state to the place that killed
all the Jews that has she been asked to
quit like no one asked her about this
hell how how is that not a top line
story I mean she is at the top of the
news and the president is making the
case she's an anti-semite and the
meteor-like no she's not an anti-semite
she's just awesome well wouldn't you ask
Nancy Pelosi whether she just pursued
this is it's mind-boggling it is
mind-boggling how bad the media are at
their jobs and how biased they are at
their jobs the media spent yesterday
defending Ilhan Omar from legitimate
critiques like her anti-semitic comments
no she's not an anti-semite how dare you
take her out of context and then she's
critiqued over her history of possible
immigration fraud not the cheesy front
of the government immigrating here but
the possibility that she's a fraud at
the government in cogman cockiness
scheme so she could bring her brother
over to the United States illegally
there's some fairly decent evidence of
that uncovered by David Steinberg over
PJ Media and reported by the Minneapolis
star-tribune I mean they're open
questions about this Jim Acosta at CNN
and ladies find you a man who loves you
like Jim Acosta loves Jim Acosta Jim
Acosta over at CNN responded to people
asking questions about this by saying
well she denied it well she denied it
when was that a journalistic standard
she denied it you guys are literally
going around saying the president from
didn't disavow a statement that he
disavowed because he claimed to disavow
the statement but she she just denies it
out right now while I guess the case
closed then I guess we're done here and
when it comes to her own anti-semitism
you've got people in the media who
continued to defend Ilhan Omar and Al
see her fellow traveler initiated to
leave who's also an anti-semite and
Ayana Presley who expresses bigotry
publicly and then suggests that all
these people you know they are they're
the best that America has to offer
but when Trump drives you this crazy
that the squad become your squad Trump's
gonna win that battle he is you guys
making a big mistake you want to
alienate the suburban women great way of
doing that is embracing the squad would
you who are in court the more Americans
see of the squad the more unpopular
they're going to be the only reason that
they're it's
digits underwater is because only about
50 60 percent of Americans even know who
these people are except for ALC no one
knows who L n amar is no one knows who
were shooted Talib is no one knows who
Ayane Presley is when they start hearing
their comments they ain't gonna like it
very much they're not gonna like it
particularly a lot and Ohana Mart I mean
this is the game that Ohana Mar is is
playing so Ilhan Omar how radical is
ohon Omar so yeah not only did she
sponsor this BDS resolution she then
announced that she was going to travel
to Israel the only reason she did that
is because what she hopes to do is
provoke Israel into denying her entry
Israel has laws on the books that deny
entry to people who are going to
propagandize on behalf of the
destruction of State of Israel BDS is an
anti-semitic policy directed at the
destruction of the State of Israel by
the way the United States has similar
policies that if you want to come in
here and talk about the overthrow of the
US government we're not going to allow
you to come over here and visit ok so
Israel has that policy and the question
is whether they allow Ilhan Omar in or
not they probably do they probably just
take the hit of allowing her to run
around with Palestinian members of Hamas
and talk about how evil Israel is and
then they let her go back and all of us
but this is the gay male henna Myra's
playing and no one is asking Pelosi
about it forget elephant Omar why is no
one asking Pelosi about that no one
meanwhile the media are just going
around talking about a wonderful these
women are they're just they're just
wonderful so you got rashida to leave an
anti-semite
Ilhan Omar not only an anti-semite but a
radical on nearly every front AOC a
deeply radical Democratic Socialist who
believes that we run in concentration
camps on our border and I Anna Presley
who expresses open bigotry and Gayle and
Gayle King of CBS talks about how how
much these folks love the country
they're just they they are the best that
America has to offer
I just met those squad the other day I
don't know them I had never talked to
any of them before that interview and
only spent 30 minutes not one of them
has ever said I hate America not one of
them has ever said I don't want to be
here in fact I would say they love this
country so much they spoke with such
pride about being in the being in
Congress they pointed out where they
said in that room and the bills that
they passed and the passion that they
have for this country and their people
and their constituents well if you sat
with them for half an hour and they
didn't openly say I hate this country
well then clearly they must love
everything about America clearly they
must they must not be radical
if they didn't come out and just say
let's burn this place to the ground
such journalism incredible journalism
okay in just a second we're gonna get to
the 2020 Democratic race we now have the
debate breakdown inside the Democratic
race because fisticuffs begin anew very
very soon we'll get to that in just one
second first let's talk about how you
can make your home safer so as you know
I take safety incredibly seriously I do
because like some members of Congress
who say that they are targeted to non
regular basis and I believe them
I am also targeted on a regular basis
the FBI arrested someone like three
months ago who is basically threatening
my life in the life of my family so I
take safety incredibly incredibly
seriously and that's why I rely on ring
at my home rings mission is to make
neighborhood safer you might already
know about their smart video doorbells
and cameras that protect millions of
people everywhere ring helps you stay
connected to your home anywhere in the
world so if there's a package delivery
or a surprise visitor you'll get an
alert you'll be able to see here speak
to them all from your phone it's
terrific
I mean ring is is one of the ways that I
keep my home safe when I'm out of town
as a subscriber you have a special offer
on a ring welcome kit available right
now at ring.com /femme the kit includes
a video doorbell and the chime Pro which
is what you need to start building a
ring of security around your home today
by the way you don't have to worry about
just security concerns it's also a lot
of people who are trying to break into
your house will ring the doorbell make
sure you're not home and then break into
your home ring prevents that from
happening because you can pick up go to
ring calm / Ben that's ring calm / Ben
for the special deal special offer on a
ring welcome kit available right now at
ring net calm / Ben go check it out
okay so I have a bunch of announcements
that I need to make to you okay
announcement numero uno next month we
are taking our backstage show on the
road for a special one-night only event
August 21st at the beautiful Terrace
theater in Long Beach California ideally
where God king Jeremy Boren Andrew
Clavin and the execrable micromoles will
be there live we'll be taking questions
we will be talking politics pop culture
answering your questions from the
audience we're definitely gonna focus on
an answering more questions really bad
on backstage about answering enough
questions but we will take a lot of your
questions plus tickets are on sale right
now at daily wire comm slash backstage
and that includes our limited VIP
packages that guarantee premium seating
photos and meet and greets with each of
us a gift from me I'm out shopping for
you right now you never know I might
get you some sort of scented candle am I
going to bring back you just don't know
so head on over to daily wire comm slash
backstage and get your tickets today it
will be epic
okay numero dos okay the second thing
that I must announce look at this I'm
learning Spanish duolingo guys okay this
Saturday marks the fiftieth anniversary
since we first put a man on the moon
exciting new podcast is out by esoteric
radio theater I've been talking about it
all week it's called Apollo 11 what we
saw it immediately rocketed to number
three on iTunes Apple podcast it's been
in the top 10 all week it's getting rave
reviews from all sorts of wonderful
people episodes 1 through 3 are out
right now episode 4 magnificent
desolation drops tomorrow the host is
Bill Whittle his author pilot knows more
about NASA than any five human beings
that I know he will give you the entire
inside scoop of what it took to get to
the moon and what happened when we got
there and how things almost went
horribly wrong there's nothing in the
podcast about how NASA was full of evil
white men and was not equal enough as
the Soviet Union was and how there
weren't any women in the space capsule
or anything so that part you're gonna
have to go to the New York Times for but
if you actually want the story of what
happened with Apollo 11 you're not gonna
get it better than Apollo 11 what we saw
subscribe today over at Apple podcasts
or wherever you listen to podcasts okay
the third thing okay is that we have our
Sunday special coming out this week our
Sunday special this week features be
fantastic Ravi Zacharias so if you are
interested in theology if you're
interested in Christianity if you are
interested in Western civilization you
should really listen to our Sunday
special this week this is why you should
subscribe this is why you should spend
the 99 bucks a year and get early access
to the Sunday special on Saturday here's
a little bit of what it sounded like
when I talk to Robbie
I think morality is good for civil
coexistence but morality alone will not
save this society unless we develop an
accountability to our Creator not merely
for moral reasoning but for the
recognition that life at its core is
sacred
ravi zacharias is a really deep
interesting thinker he's he's terrific
to sit with him what a nice guy
so go listen to the Sunday special this
week it really is terrific also I mean
so many announcements guys it's that
glorious time of the week when I give a
shout out to a daily wire subscriber
today and his Twitter user Jenna who
clearly has two of life's greatest
blessings to be thankful for first I
left his tears hot or cold tumblr and
second and off-the-charts adorable baby
boy I mean look at that baby that is a
handsome baby my goodness in this pic
baby Harper who's dressed in a
fashionable yellow onesie is just
chilling outside chillin in Des Moines
like Hillary Clinton on some patio
furniture while holding the world's
greatest beverage vessel and looking
like a million that is a cute baby okay
so I'm a sucker for babies I love babies
and that is that is a cute baby the
caption reads raised on breast milk and
left his tears that is some solid
momming right there solid combo for the
baby grew up to be big and strong like
water
fantastic picture thank you baby Harper
and Jennifer your support that is some
awesome stuff okay so go subscribe
ninety-nine bucks a year get see the
annual that's the one that you want it
also helps us it protects us against the
the evils of Media Matters and their
idiot and their idiot employees who
spend all day trolling and trying to
find clips they can take out of context
so they can attack us and attack our
advertisers and and just be general
pains in the ass if you don't want to
embolden those folks help ensure that
our show is brought to you along all the
lines that you want to be brought to you
by subscribing and become part of the
team that's how you help us out we
really appreciate it we're the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
all right so moving forward from the
Trump versus Ilhan Omar brouhaha to the
2020 race which seems to have taken a
backseat here and it's fascinating I was
watching the poll numbers as all this
happened so if you watch the poll
numbers at RealClearPolitics while all
of this was happening what you see is
that Joe Biden is actually crimen again
kind of fascinating in the Real Clear
Politics poll average he had dropped
down to about 26% as of maybe a week and
a half ago right as of July fifth this
is two weeks ago he was down to 26% and
now in the Real Clear Politics poll
average he's up to 28% and that is
because the less people look at the
Democrats the more they're like you know
what we want just the moderate guy like
the guy who seems kind of moderate how
about that guy let's do that guy now is
28% enough for Joe Biden to win the
nomination no I think the Joe Biden is
not going to be the nominee
I think the Joe Biden's best day as I've
been saying consistently throughout this
campaign his best day was his first day
that will remain true Joe Biden is 100%
name recognition and he doesn't even
have 30 percent support in the
Democratic primaries the next debates
are not going to be good for him I
predict the reason being the breakdown
of the debates so the Democrats have
decided to do these debates in the
dumbest possible way so what the
Republicans did is they tried to in 2016
as they tried to have debates with the
top contenders and then there was sort
of the kids table the kids table was for
the people who like the arocs wall wells
of the world in the Republican Party who
are going to get two percent in the
polls and then they could automate each
other and maybe one of them would rise
up like Carly Fiorina and then it would
be included in the big person debate and
not that that was a much better way of
doing it the Democrats however in the
name of anti meritocracy have decide
because they're not merit they're not in
favor of merit they've decided instead
that they're just going to basically
draw straws for who is in which debate
and there's still one bajillion
candidates the only candidate shockingly
the only candidate with enough reason to
see he's going nowhere with sois well
man this party so here's how this all
breaks down so there are two debates
there are two debates the first night
debate is Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth
Warren and Pete Budaj edge and bethe
O'Rourke Amy Klobuchar Steve Bullock
representative Tim Ryan from Ohio John
Hickenlooper John Delaney and Marianne
Williamson so first of all
I will watch anything with marianne
williamson it I don't I don't care what
it is I don't care if it's a special on
on healing oils I don't care if it's
about crystals I don't care
Marianne Williamson isn't the best and I
will watch that debate just to watch
Marianne Williamson talk about binding
the president with chains of love which
is real Fifty Shades of Grey kind of
stuff
real weird Marianne Williamson is great
and I want more Marianne Williamson on
the stage but people are basically
declaring that there is a white person
debate and then there is a diverse
people debate because every person on
that stage is white so it's Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren now that's
really good for Warren because Warren
can go directly at Sanders and continue
to carve away at his base it's bad for
people who to judge because he's gonna
be a sideshow he booted judges left out
of that main battle Buddha judges raised
an enormous amount of cash but you want
to talk it's fascinating how the media
coverage works here so Pete Moody judge
raised insane amounts of money he raised
more money than pretty much anybody in
the last quarter and he is polling in
the Real Clear Politics poll average at
4.8% mater O'Rourke is polling at two
point eight percent better work is
considered a giant fail peabody judge is
considered a giant success so why why
well because people who judge is
intersectionally diverse because he's a
gay man and that means he has to get
outsized media attention he's raised
enormous amounts of cash that's not
translating into anything that looks
like success anywhere in latest Hill
poll he has 1% won so and then in case
Buddha judge is not really a force in
this race I think the Buddha judge
boomlet is over that's gonna be about
the 1st of it will be about Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren going at
each other and aimin claw which are
going guys I'm the only senator in
America who wildly outpaces in
popularity my party why in the world am
I not getting anywhere here and her
throwing binders of people and then it's
a bunch of randos and marianne
williamson who's the best okay that's
that's debate night number one debate
night number two is Joe Biden and Kamala
Harris so it's the rematch it's rocky to
the rematch so can Biden get up off the
mat and go at Harris he's gonna need to
he's gonna be a needle to be a lot more
adapt against Harris but Biden is now
facing down the 2-headed attack of
Kamala Harris and Cory Booker because
Cory Booker is sitting there going I
started this thing right I'm the one who
tact Biden first and then he put me in
the other debate where I couldn't attack
Biden so now I want to attack Biden
publicly so Cory Booker is gonna bring
his angry eyes I've said that he's like
mr. Potato Head he brings his angry eyes
he always has to bring his eye and then
he pops him in and now it's angry Cory
bar angry so we'll see if Cory Booker
and Kamala Harris go after Joe Biden
Biden's gonna have to handle himself
really well this is again very risky for
Joe Biden I don't think he will because
I don't think that he's capable of doing
that he's looking very old out there on
the campaign trail if you've seen video
of him he it's not that that's not a rip
on on his age as a number that's a rip
on how he is performing as a candidate
he is looking doddering he is not
looking stable he is not looking as
though he has this thing under control
he's not looking energetic there are
other Elizabeth Warren is 70 and she's
looking energetic out there Joe Biden
simply is not he's got a few years on
more and but Warren is way more
energetic
so Biden versus Harrison Booker and then
there's my my dude and my boy Andrew
yang the the only candidate with the
actual stones to come on the Sunday
special we've invited every single one
of these Democrats none of them will
come on the Sunday special despite the
fact that I treat everybody really well
on the Sunday special though look at my
my interview with Andrew yang I treated
him great because the Sunday special is
about exchange of ideas it's not about
attack it's not about debate is about
discussion
it'll be Booker who Leon Castro who I
guess we'll just be there first and
Gillibrand who bill de blasio who will
be very tall and strangle groundhogs
Senator Michael Bennet of Colorado the
only rational person left in the
Democratic Party Tulsi Gabbard of Hawaii
and Washington governor jay Inslee
who'll rant and rave about climate
change while being completely useless so
that is the that is the breakdown of the
debates my prediction continued momentum
for Harris continued momentum for Warren
Biden is gonna have to turn into hell of
a response in order for him to regain
the momentum okay meanwhile Joe Biden is
struggling for his argument he continues
to sort of trot out the same arguments
over and over but here's the thing Joe
Biden because he is attempting to head
off the Democrats of the past the
Radical Democrats of the past because of
all that Joe Biden is now engaging in
exactly the kind of politicking that
lost Hillary Clinton the 2016 election
so here was Joe Biden yesterday being
asked about President Trump
and Joe Biden didn't just go after Trump
he proceeded to go after Trump's base he
suggested that people who voted for
President Trump are racist this is
exactly the same as when Hillary Clinton
suggested and everyone who is thinking
about voting for Trump was a deplorable
was a member of the alt-right
which was full right here's Joe Biden
suggesting the Trump space is racist how
is this a smart electoral strategy you
got me I don't think it is I always saw
it the way you stood there it didn't
seem like it it assumes you can imagine
if someone said that when I was look
this is a game this is about dividing
the country this is about dividing and
raising the issue of
racism across the country because that's
his face okay so it's rigs to sum across
that that's his bases bases racist good
good pitch there Joe Biden very smart
pitch right there pretty amazing stuff
and meanwhile Bernie Sanders is running
into some problems of his own this is a
delicious story so Bernie Sanders has
been pushing for $15 minimum wage
federally mandated the House of
Representatives just passed a bill that
would mandate federal minimum wage of
$15 according to the Congressional
Budget Office this would result in a
minimum of 1.3 million jobs lost but
sure we got to talk about minimum wage
so why not just pick a random point and
say that should be the minimum wage only
one problem
quote Washington Post headline labor
fight Royals Bernie Sanders campaign as
workers demand the $15 hourly pay the
candidate has proposed for employees
nationwide woopsie turns out that Bernie
Sanders hasn't been paying his folks 15
bucks an hour campaign filled tires have
demands in the annual salary they say
would be equivalent to a $15 an hour
wage which standards for years has said
should be the federal minimum the
organizers and other employees
supporting them have invoked the
Senators words and principles and making
their case to the campaign manager if I
use Shakir the documents reviewed by The
Washington Post show so Bernie Sanders
not living up to his socialist of
bonafide ease that in his three houses
and his unlimited supply of pudding
suggests that he may not actually abide
by his own dictates there's a problem
for Kamala Harris to actually as long as
we are talking about problems for
Democrats in the 2020 presidential race
according to the Washington Examiner
Kamala Harris his presidential campaign
bio rest heavily on her career as a
prosecutor including six years as
California Attorney General but it omits
a plea deal her office negotiated for
former San Diego mayor Bob Filner a
serial sexual harasser which let him
escape jail time and avoid registering
as a sex offender I remember this case
I'm from California we covered it Bob
Filner was trapping women in booths at
the lake the local Bennie's and then
sexually harassing them in the booth in
2013 about 20 women accused film there
are two decades Democratic congressman
tour in San Diego mayor of sexual
harassment and misconduct some said he
put them in I could do not film their
headlocks Harris's office through
considerable criticism in 2013 for
allowing Filner to plead guilty to state
charges of false imprisonment and bad
against three jane doe's in exchange for
light sentence filmer could have faced
up to five years in prison but the plea
guard hard bargain instead gave him
three months of house arrest three years
probation and partial loss of his
mayoral pension not complete loss oh
he's still getting paid some of the
criticism persists today with past
lenient sentences looking less
understandable after a swath of
prominent men drummed themselves out of
public life over sexual harassment
episodes so here's the thing if Joe
Biden wants to go after kamo Harris
she is a target-rich environment but
he's actually gonna have to go after her
so if she starts with the race stuff
again Joe Biden should say to her
listen kamoi you and I both know you
don't support federal busing the
difference is that I'm honest about my
position whereas you lie about your
position you suggest that because I take
the exact same position you do on
federal busing and did in the 1970s that
this is because I am a bigot and yet you
today do not support federal busing and
this and schools are de-facto more
segregated than they were then not to
jury Digory means by law and so he can
go after her on that he can say listen
Pamela you purport to be this fighter
for the people you're lying to everybody
you're suggesting the medicare-for-all
is possible without a middle-class tax
hike at least Bernie Sanders is honest
you're a damn liar he should say to her
listen you won't even make clear your
own position on Medicare for all you
have no less than 60 times changed your
position on private health insurance and
whether it ought to be eliminated hey
you are a person who
campaigns on this notion that you are a
strong prosecutor who's going to stand
up to criminality particularly
criminality directed at women well how
about that Bob Filner plea deal huh what
do you got on there Joe Biden is gonna
have to aggressively go after her
because sort of like in 2016 a lot of
Republicans were resonating to the idea
that President Trump would be the best
person to prosecute Hillary on the stage
cuz he had no limits and he'd say
anything there is a feeling among
Democrats they need the best prosecutor
of Trump on that stage too Biden has not
shown himself to be that he's thrown out
the same sorts of lines over and over
and over quick sidenote on Joe Biden
remember that clip we played a minute
ago of Joe Biden saying he would have
stood up and told the crowd no if the
crowd had started saying bad things he
literally told the crowd in 2012 that
Mitt Romney was going to put black
people back in Chains and they cheered
so no Joe Biden I don't think that
you're innocent in all of this a
Democrat
party it's amazing as I said over the
past couple of days we are now playing a
game of hold my beer
basically Donald Trump will say hold my
beer are gonna do something crazy and
then the Democrats will say no no you
hold the beer I'm gonna do something
crazy and then Trump's like no no no I'm
gonna do something crazy hold the beer
and Democrats would be like well what if
we just embraced the squad hold the beer
does anyone want to win in 2020 election
like I really like this anyway
apparently nobody wants to win
apparently everybody just wants to yell
at each other and Club each other with
mallets does any this is like Who Framed
Roger Rabbit
eventually the only one left standing is
gonna be judge doom like that this is
just it's utter insanity its total
craziness all the way through okay time
for some things I like and then instead
of things I hate I'm gonna do a little
bit of mailbag so things I like today as
you know again I get my relaxation for
meeting sports books there's a very good
little sports book about hard-luck
harvey Haddix so the greatest baseball
game ever pitched was a game in 1959
pitched by Harvey Haddix he pitched a
perfect game that means that he he got
everyone out he every single batter he
faced he got out for nine innings and
then he did it for another three innings
he pitched to 12 innings of perfect
baseball and then he lost the game in
the 13th so he pitched a perfect game
for 12 innings and then he lost the game
in the 13th inning it's the greatest
game ever pitched and the book is all
about that game and it's it's pretty
pretty wild stuff so you should check
out the book again hard-luck harvey
Haddix and the greatest game ever lost
by Lou Friedman if you're a baseball fan
this is for you okay time for a thing I
hate and by that I mean mail bag I don't
hate the mail bag so let's just do the
mail bag many says I'm 24 years old I
recently developed an intimate
relationship with someone much my senior
she's 36 almost 37 she is pregnant
I feel heartbroken and like my life is
over I'm not ready for a child and did
not see us together long term she does
not want an abortion I come from a
religious family I've recently gotten
into politics my view on abortion have
shifted a fairly pro-life but when it is
myself in the situation it feels so
different and he says I understand if
you don't read this on your show I
appreciate everything you do and you
mean a lot thank you for being it well
Mindy I mean time for some bad news okay
the bad news is that obviously actions
have consequences here's the good news
the good news is you get to be a dad
being a
is the best thing in the entire world I
have two kids they are unbelievable
they're gonna make your life so much
richer they've been making life so much
better and guess what you being a
responsible human being is gonna make
you a better person and you have a
responsibility with this woman to make a
life for your child it's not about you
and this woman anymore it's about you
and this woman and your child it's about
you becoming a better person for having
to work around somebody who you may have
to learn to live with it's about you
making sure that the next generation is
well taken care of be a dad
to your own kid preserve the life of
your kid listen not every mistake has to
end up being an life-changing horrifying
mistake sometimes the best things in
life started as mistakes
I mean fascinating statistic you back to
1930s 1940s a heavy percentage I think
if not a plurality a heavy minority of
all births in the United States were
so-called shotgun wedding births I mean
it was there are a lot of preemies back
in the 1930s and 40s a lot of people who
are getting pregnant and then two months
later getting married and then seven
months later the baby is born they say
oh well look at that the baby just came
a little bit early that was very very
common in American life an American life
wasn't worse for that when people
married people based on the fact that
they wanted to raise the child now your
priorities have to shift the reason you
got yourself in this situation is
because you weren't thinking about the
future you weren't thinking about
anybody beyond yourself to be perfectly
frank and now you have to think about
something beyond yourself and that will
be very good for you and will be great
for your kid and that's what really
matters in the end
Shaye says hey Ben our dark thoughts
equally as bad as dark actions the dark
thoughts even count to sins the same way
actions do thanks chase no I don't think
they do I think that this at least in
the Jewish view the answer is no and
certainly the public policy view the
answer is no so there's certain dark
thoughts that you cannot prevent like if
I tell you not to think of an elephant
right now you know you're doing thinking
of an elephant so your brain sometimes
just goes to dark places yeah but it
depends on how much it affects action I
care about action I can't police what
you're thinking I don't know what you're
thinking unless you say it and I don't
know what you're thinking unless you do
it so no I don't think that thoughts are
the same as dark actions at all as far
as sinfulness that one's up to God and
you're gonna have to deal with God on
that level because he's the only one who
can tell what's inside your head Paul
says hey Ben how do you explain God your
kids it's a tricky explanation I'm sure
kids ask a million questions
well the way I explain God's my kids
there's a creator of the unit
so you look at the world around you it
seems to have a particular order the
reason that it seems to have rules and
laws is because there was a rule maker
and a lawgiver and there and because
that is true there are certain actions
you can take in your life that
predictably will make your life better
as a general rule and God wants you to
do that because God cares about you and
God loves you because God created you
and what could be a greater act of love
than creation Zack says hi Ben
I'm a graduate student who will be
graduating in December with my master's
in biology I'm going into forensic
science I'm doing an internship with a
forensic lab at this coming fall
semester what would be the best way to
make the most of this opportunity and
potentially turn it into a job after and
use it to the market myself post-grad
thanks well if you are going into a
internship and you're interning in a
forensic lab get on some papers
obviously see if you can you can make
connections I mean that's really how you
should be seeking every job at this
point what kind of connections can you
make what kind of resume building can
you do what kind of research can you do
what kind of skill sets can you broaden
that's how you should approach every job
Charles says hello Ben if you could have
a Sunday special with one of the
founding fathers who would it be and
what questions would you ask love the
show it would be Adams because I think
Adams was the most kind of interesting
thinker on the one hand Adams was a
perennial deep political and personal
convictions he was somebody who was who
was a deep believer in the rights to due
process and free speech at the same time
when it came to practical governance he
helped pass the alien Sedition Acts he
was president at the time he had
significant arguments with Thomas
Jefferson over the nature and role of
the federal government I think that he's
a really interesting figure I think I
understand Jefferson pretty well but
Adams is a little bit more enigmatic and
quite brilliant and a wonderful writer
okay final question let us see Carson
said actually let's do this um Shura
says - right now I'm considering going
to law school after college do you think
it's worth investing the time money if
I'm not entirely sure I want to practice
as an attorney thanks for all you do
well you have to assess what skillset
you're actually gonna receive from law
school I went to law school I wasn't
sure I was gonna practice law I don't
but it taught me to think in a certain
way also credentialing does matter so it
matters where you go to law school so if
it's just I'm gonna get a law degree and
that's about it and it does the crown
jewel doesn't matter to me and the skill
set doesn't matter to me and I may not
practice then no but if the credential
matters and the skill set matters then
sure that's something that's valuable
beyond
simply the practice of law alrighty well
we will be back here next Monday I'm off
for the radio show later today but I
will be back here next Monday with all
three hours have yourself a wonderful
weekend I mention para this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Joshua
alvera production assistant Nick Sheehan
the Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
hey guys over on the Matt Walsh show
today Democrats just passed a bill that
would raise the minimum wage to $15 an
hour now I'm gonna explain why not only
do I disagree with a $15 minimum wage I
actually think the minimum wage should
be zero also a measure that was passed
in California a couple years ago has now
made it so that thieves can walk into
basically any store any convenience
store they want and steal whatever they
want essentially without consequence
we'll discuss that finally the scariest
trailer scariest movie trailer of all
time was released yesterday I'm not
talking about it much scarier than that
and I'll play that for you today on the
Matt Walsh show